sophie turner proves she's just as
badass as her Game of Thrones character
how do you answer these charges we think
Sophie officially earned her title as
the best start to party with 100% it all
went down on a date night with her
fiance Joe Jonas at a New York Rangers
hockey game when Sophie got caught on
Jumbotron she went in dabbing and
downing a glass of red wine for all the
sea
[Applause]
this is my girl right yeah it's pretty
epic move might even be thrown worthy
Sophie shared that vid and she called
out her Game of Thrones character Sansa
Stark in the caption writing send it for
the Starks guys I'm ready to take a page
out of Sophie's party book she is so
badass she was it 5 o'clock yet
Sophie's famous friends and family were
also impressed by Sophie reacting to her
Instagram post in the comments Drake
wrote Wow inspiration for 2020 and
beyond Ashley Graham hyped her simply
saying my girl soon-to-be brother-in-law
Nick Jonas said oh my god sporting
events seem to be Jo and Sophie's go to
date night yeah sometimes they even make
it a double date with Nick and Priyanka
Chopra Jonas here they are watching a
tennis match and just weeks ago and they
were at a basketball game packing on the
PDA the actress was also the life of the
party shouting from the stands she's a
true sports fan in love that we love
that Sophie's a big sports fan and that
Jo's a big Sophie fan and a Sansa fan I
got a no is Joe rooting for sunset to
end up on the Iron Throne I don't know I
don't know we didn't talk about it we
loved blush yeah or I'm sweaty I can
tell well that's hashtag couple goals in
my opinion these two are the sweetest
Sophie just opened up about how Joe
played a major role in helping her find
herself she told glamour UK quote I
think for the longest time I didn't have
a real sense of myself adding a lot of
my happiness now is to do with being
with a person I've fallen in love with
who loves me more than he loves himself
and who wants to see me find my own
happiness
[Music]
baby Sophie is also a sucker for her man
in real life there Sophie cozying up to
an old Jonas Brother poster of her
fiance like a true fangirl and Joe
hilariously drooling over Sophie in this
3 second photo booth challenge during
the Joe Broz week-long take over on The
Late Late Show with James Corden damn we
look good together
voila Joe wins this challenge how'd I do
if I was living like a an equal sign not
a peace sign
Joe mean I get Sophie's full stamp of
approval for his selfie taking skills
but the actress gets major props from us
for those chugging chops
yes girl of course we'll keep you
up-to-date with all the latest on this
cute couple until next time I'm Hallie
Stephen and I'm Courtney tezo
[Music]